did  should the court take that into  accountability or into consideration oh  let's not send him to jail i understand  what you're saying um but i feel like if  you're stealing and you're addict you're  ultimately putting this kid in danger  anyways uh-huh but if you just told  someone which is really bad as well that  they're their father  you're not putting the kid in that much  danger yeah but you're stealing time and  resources  and i agree from another person so in  essence like you could take the drug  addict off of it let's just say he was  stealing like it's the same thing you're  just stealing resources time and time  it's almost worse actually to pin a kid  like i don't i just don't it shouldn't  matter if the person is a kid or not it  should matter like did they commit the  crime or did they not commit the crime  like in my eyes that should be a crime